hello everyone welcome back to the
cinema center at marble at Tiff 2023 I
am lucky enough to talk to two people
behind one of my favorite films of the
festival national anthem congratulations
huge congratulations to both of you
thank you so much thank you so much it
made me very sad to miss this at South
by Southwest but now the time has come
you are meant to be here so our viewers
might not know about national anthem
just yet so Luke I'm going to give you
the the big question of the day can you
give a brief synopsis of your film
national anthem is a western for the new
world it's a love story
it's uh told through the experience of
Dylan played by the brilliant Charlie
Palmer who is a construction worker in
New Mexico 21 years old takes care of
his younger brother and his alcoholic
mother he accepts a gig working at the
house of Splendor which is a homestead
built by a community of queer ranchers
and Rodeo performers and is welcomed
into the community and given the space
to discover himself and fall in love for
the first time and find the multitudes
within himself that he didn't yet know
existed nailed it beautiful description
didn't break a sweat I love it so this
is your first feature but I know you had
a lot of music video directing
experience beforehand so jumping into
your first feature what is a particular
learning curve that you experience but
then also what is a unique tool that
music video directing gave you that came
in handy here uh I would say visual
story time and I also started with
photography and and learning how to tell
a story and uh you know so few frames
and also you know working with someone
so deeply talented as Charlie too
there's just so much he's able to tell
so much of a story just with his eyes
you know and to
um and uh body language so that is a
huge tool I think of of learning just
how to economically tell a story
visually too I would say learning curve
um is uh working with so many different
uh you know formers and actors and with
so many different
levels of experience and backgrounds and
and wanting to support each one and and
their journey of how the best way for
them to work but everyone has a
different way of working you know so oh
I am coming back to that idea at a
minute but first uh Charlie I wanted to
ask you about picking first time feature
filmmakers to work with because we were
just talking about Brian um Matt
Smuggler comes to mind you seem to have
a knack for doing it so do you find that
all those directors have a shared
quality that signals to you yes they can
direct a film and also they'll be good
collaborators for me oh man I mean I
don't know if they all have a shared
quality but I do think there has to be
something that speaks to you I think
with Luke you know the thing that was
immediately with us was music was
something that we immediately connected
on really before we seriously spoke
about fully doing it together we were
just Loosely speaking about the script
and the story and the character and then
he sent me this playlist that he had
been making for months for the film some
of it had songs that were in the script
as well but I just devoured that within
a day and music for me is a huge tool as
an actor and so this was really the
first director that I ever had worked
with where music was such a major
influence in how they wrote the story
but then also how they saw the story
continually and we continually went back
to music I mean even songs that we would
find on set and I would just pull them
aside and be like oh my God this is
perfect for the film and even if we
never use it I just want to learn how to
play it and play it while we're making
it because it just the music really does
provide such a a beautiful perspective
in ways that it's hard to put words to
sometimes and I think for us that was
such a wonderful tool that we got to use
to explore this story and these
characters and and that was a first time
experience for me working with the
director so that was something that
specifically with this was was so
special right from the beginning hearing
that answer makes me think you should do
a movie musical next we just had John
Carney in this morning for Lauren son
and I feel
like you work together I just like to
manifest things that I want to see
happen here so go work go work with them
I'll definitely call him I wanted to
refer to something you said in your
director statement you were talking
about how you came to realize how
homophobic mainstream Rodeo can be and I
am curious now having made this film is
there anything that young you first
realizing that would see in this movie
that would make him go like my God I am
proud I was able to bring that to screen
one day what a great question thank you
um I think that so many queer stories
and so much of the queer experience
unfortunately
um being in the world is about survival
and is about trauma you know so all the
queer stories that we've seen on screen
have been you know tragedies so I am so
moved that we were able to tell a story
that is about Hope and
um about the beauty of these safe spaces
that have have existed since the dawn of
time queer people have existed and been
creating these spaces so that to me I
think a young version of myself would be
really inspired by that there's a
beautiful warmth to this movie that I
really appreciated and desperately
needed to see right now so I appreciate
that quite a bit Charlie for you talking
a little bit about Dylan now going into
filming what particular quality of his
were you most looking forward to playing
but then I also want to know the part of
his experience that wound up being more
creatively fulfilling to dig into than
you ever could have imagined oh wow
that's a wonderful question I mean
crushing it with the questions
gotta make sure my questions match the
quality of the movie you bring in wow
well there you go that's it that's the
interview I think we're done no
um I I think for for the character I
mean going in I think something I was
really excited about I mean you know
I've kind of been obsessed with being
like a wannabe cowboy for such a long
time and speaking to Luke who's an
actual cowboy and understanding that
what he was wanting to do with this was
create a classic Western love story but
taking this Cowboy archetype that has
been the idea of the American man in so
many ways and finding a much more full
perspective of what that really means
and in this case really embracing the
side of femininity with this person and
I think that was the thing I was most
excited about about really like
witnessing in myself as much as through
the story both of those energies coming
together to be in this one human and
that was really really wonderful to get
to live out and and then really I think
the thing that just I was so stressed
about going in and then really did prove
to be such a monumentally profound
experience for me was the drag
performance that Dylan gets to have and
you know something that I've been such a
fan of the art form of drag Precision a
long time and had such a respect from
afar for what those performers are able
to do but then like actually going
through the rehearsals and like humbling
myself and stuff really how much work I
really had to do and then of course on
the day Luke just being like forget all
of that and just trust what's there and
like that's it and I knew he was gonna
say that but I still spent so many weeks
trying to get all those moves down and
so for him to say that and just break
that open that was such a profound
experience and really letting that out
and hopefully that's what people see in
the scene so I think that was really
really special and something I'll always
look back on exceptional scene and
seeing him share that with his little
brother too it just like filled my heart
real life his little brother was there
who's a huge drag fan so I feel like my
brother is like biggest fan of dragon
has been for years he wanted to be a
queen his name is Charlemagne sassy
Bashi Beverly Hills that's his Dragon
um I would be in big trouble if I didn't
give him a shout out so I flew him out
for that one scene because it was really
meaningful because of course that's a
huge Dynamic with Dylan and his brother
and for me that was huge I mean drag has
been a way for us and continually I mean
every time I go home it's who won
Canadian drag race who won U.S drag race
who won Australian drag race I mean it's
insane how many there are now everything
the brother says in this movie is just
like it's another one of those things
where every line I'm like that's exactly
what I needed to hear from such a young
person right now it's nice to have a
character like that in this film
speaking of that character and also all
of the supporting characters in this
movie I want to go back to what you were
saying about about uh actors having
different processes before can you maybe
pick two members of this Ensemble who
have different approaches to the work
where it called for something different
from you as an actor's director
um I would say well the first one that
comes to mind is
um is his brother in the film
um I've you know we really wanted for
that to be an authentic relationship and
so working collaborating with Charlie on
that and Joey is his name in real life
the actor who plays him Cassidy is the
character's name so
um Cassidy is written to to be sort of a
savant you know and when I met Joey he
was so much of that like as soon as I
met him he was like did you know this
and did you know that and
um and it just felt immediately like
Cassidy and so
um but I I know that a lot of kids when
they start to read scripts and learn
lines it becomes this thing that they do
over and over again and it becomes like
meaningless
um so I chose not to share the script
and to basically keep it all Improv
and I think that that was
um a really interesting way for us to
work so that it really felt uh fresh and
new in the moment with them
um so but that also meant that
rehearsals were different it was more
about them building a relationship and a
rapport which I feel is so moving it was
really moving to watch them do that it
was very real what was your reaction to
finding out that you would have to film
something that way is that exciting or
is it intimidating I mean it was
exciting because I think there's such a
trust between Luke and I that when he
said that it just Honestly made sense
because especially after I met Joey and
as a former child actor I know that the
way kids are taught especially you know
when they're starting out is to kind of
be perfectionist about the material and
try to find a formula that works and so
you know oftentimes kids come to a set
on the first day and have a very clear
idea of how they're going to do it and
what Luke was wanting with this film was
really the opposite from all of the
performances and really kind of leaving
space
for something else to kind of come up
throughout the scene and so with Joey I
think it just made more sense for us to
like have an understanding of where the
scene would need to go and to of course
have that conversation with him
beforehand but also make sure that we
were never like you know locking into
one way of doing anything and I think
that's where a lot of these really
special moments like especially the
scene that I think just came out that
people can see where I come home and
he's helping me take off my makeup you
know so much of that was just the truth
of him and how he was responding to me
and that is what's so beautiful it was
like one take it was all just in the
moment of their honest interaction so
that was a really inspiring way for us
to to bring out the truth and the the
heart of the scene you know not the
whole movie was that way with everyone
else but the scenes with Joey playing
Cassidy worse so it was I think a cool
way for us to keep things fresh and
interesting too and find effect of
choice thank you I love that to lupins
we've got Joey now to Loop in another
actor in this Ensemble Charlie can you
maybe pinpoint someone who is just like
exactly the scene partner you needed for
a really challenging scene where what
they did helped you access something in
Dylan that you might not have been able
to reach without them absolutely I mean
that's a pretty easy answer I think
Lucas I'm gonna say with this but um
Mason Alexander park who plays Carrie in
the film I mean I think the relationship
between Carrie and Dylan and the film
reflects this but I do think Carrie is
such a grounding Force for Dylan and is
really Dylan's you know best friend and
truest friend and I just felt like every
scene that I had with Mason I mean
actually the first thing that I had with
Mason in which they were doing yard work
or something and I just come up to them
and we're just chatting I mean that
alone it was just like oh my God
whatever this Dynamic is in this
chemistry and this energy I just need to
be a part of that and and then it
carried through until the final scene
that I have with them and where they're
really holding me and
they're a a person who as just actors I
feel such a safety with such a trust
with and for that scene in particular
because that was so much of what the
scene was about and Carrie is a
character really allowing Dylan to see
his future and to feel safe in seeing
his future and to feel held and seeing
his future to not be scared of that you
know that meant so much to me and of
course you know it always reverberates
you know all the layers and and I think
Mason like really wonderfully at South
by we got to have a really wonderful
moment together after the film where I
think we both really shared just how
much that meant to one another and and
also seeing that in the film when you
know that you know it's validating to
get to witness it again on camera so
amazing I'm so grateful for them yeah
there's a conversation with them and
it's just they they like radiate this
this warmth and this energy that you
can't get enough of and you just want to
sit in that room with them all day long
another person I wanted a loop here in
uh on is uh Caitlyn your cinematographer
so I'm a big fan of some of her other
work as well when you're looking for a
cinematographer for something like this
what do you see in her that signals to
you like not only is she good at her job
and can help me execute my vision but
she can also add to it and elevate it
throughout the process oh man there was
really no one else I wanted to work with
I think especially coming from a
photography background I'm so visual and
so it's you know it was very important
part person to be collaborating with you
know in some a decision I did not take
lightly but it was so clearly her for me
because yes she's immensely talented and
um there's just phenomenal depth to her
vision and uh so many layers in terms of
how
um she sees the material and what she
brings to it but also just our
personalities it really comes down to
that of the way that we genuinely want
to be hanging out with each other all
the time and it's to you know especially
working on indie films like this like
you really become family and
um I think the themes of the film start
to come alive behind the scenes as well
and for this it's family and so she
really much is very much is that and
um so yeah it's so much her personality
all right I'm gonna end with a a big
question for both of you but first
feature again and then also you're doing
some things that you've never done
before in this film so what is something
that you managed to accomplish on
National Anthem that I don't know maybe
makes certain filmmaking goals feel more
in reach than ever where you've pushed
yourself so far that you know you can
hit another level you've always dreamed
of hitting
foreign
I think for me there's so many
individual moments to go through there I
mean obviously that drive performance is
one of them but I think for me quite
honestly it was it's maybe a cop-out
answer but it really was the whole
experience like just how intimate our
first conversation about the script felt
and it felt like it was really just us
and sharing this vision and
understanding and then for I think less
than a year later for that to be done
and for us to have made that film and
had that experience I've never been a
part of something from that kind of a
stage and then to witness it grow into
that in that way that was really special
usually I come on at a later stage and
this was quite honestly like the most a
directors ever trusted me as a
collaborator in the fullest sense you
know and I think that was for me as an
actor such a
reinvigorating and
just like eye-opening and unbelievable
experience you get to have because that
power of collaboration that ultimately
he had the choice of trusting me with or
not trusting me with and he chose to
trust me with that that gave the
experience so much more life and it made
it feel so much more full than anything
I could have imagined and that really is
what I want to do now moving forward and
I've only gotten to make one other thing
since then but fortunately I really felt
like that feeling was there and making
it and I really you know bring bring it
back to that bond that we had and that
very first conversation and just
trusting that feeling and then
witnessing that become this film of the
story so it's such a beautiful answer
the pressure's on now well I mean
absolutely as you can see we have a very
special connection and so I think that
is a big thing is I really want to work
with Charlie again and more so that's a
big one of just seeing how profound and
deep and meaningful that relationship
can be
um but also with so much of the crew we
were able to really hand pick everyone
because it wasn't a huge production so
you know there were so many women there
were so many people of color there were
so many queer people and I think with a
lot of the conversations happening right
now it's inspiring to see that you know
people are fighting for more
um respect and that was something that
from the very beginning was so important
to us was for people to be treated
fairly and with respect and care and so
I really want to be you know fighting
for more of that and to keep that going
it was so beautiful to see and for the
producers to support that and
um so it was to me a really inspiring
example that that is possible you can be
done and to keep going I'll be greedy
you've you haven't even released this
movie out into the whole world yet but I
I want more of exactly what you just
said so I am rooting for both of you and
for this movie thank you so much for
your time congratulations thank you and
a reminder to everybody out there
national anthem do not miss it and stay
tuned more from Tiff 2023 coming your
way very soon